كنا في بدايه هذه النشره قد تابعنا صورا
كانت لحام كتائب القسام مع قوات الاحتلال
في مدينه غزه في المغازي او في مخيم
البريج او حتى استهدافات سرايا القدس ل
تجمعات قوات الاحتلال بقذائف
الهاون اولا اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن هذه
الصور ما هي المعاني العسكريه التي يمكن
فهمها من خلال هذه الصور والاستهداف التي
تابعناها ايه حسن ايه المعنى ان اي
المقاومه بدات تعيد تنظيم نفسها يعني اذا
اعتبرنا ان هناك 12 كتيبه في الشمال هذه
الكتيبه التي تدعي اسرائيل انها انزلت او
خفضت قدراتها القتاليه ولم تعد ق قادره
على القتال كوحده ومنظومه عسكريه هي قادره
اليوم على اعاده التنظيم جغرافيا يعني في
كل كل منطقه اعاده التموضع اعاده التمركز
اعاده التنظيم لماذا لان الجيش الاسرائيلي
في قياس نجاحه يطبق المعادلات التي تنطبق
وتقاس عليها الجيوش التقليديه انه مدى
الجوزيه ومتى تصبح الوحده غير جاهزه اليوم
هي قادره من ذلك بدانا نرى الاستعمال
الكثيف للطيران في مدينه غزه وشمال غزه
لان الجيش الاسرائيلي من هذه المنطقه
للمرحله الثالثه تموضع حول مدينه غزه حول
الشمال وبالتالي وضع في الوسط قوات قادره
على التدخل في جنوب المدينه وعلى التدخل
باتجاه الوسط اي باتجاه المخيمات اما في
المخيمات فهذا امر مهم جدا هي قادره على
القتال تقريبا اربعه كتائب في الوسط دائما
تضرب الخطوط اللوجستيه هذا الامر يدل
التكرار من جحر الديك وهذه المناطق يدل ان
الوسط دائما هو خط اساسي يرتاح فيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي للذهاب الى جنوب غزه او الذهاب
الى الجنوب قطاع غزه باتجاه المخيمات او
خانيونس فاذا هذا هو الاستهداف اما منطقه
الجنوب في خانيونس فهي امر مختلف تماما لا
تزال المعارك في اوجها كما يقال لكن
اللافت في في مقابل هذه المعارك
والالتحامات سيد الياس ان جيش الاحتلال
يقلص تواجده داخل قطاع غزه واعلن عن ا في
اطار هذا التقليص عن اخراج اللواء الخامس
من القطاع ايضا كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذه
المفارقه
ايه هو يعتبر انه انتقل الى المرحله
الثالثه ايه حسن هناك ثلاث مقاربات
تكتيكيه عملتيه لجيش الاحتلال في في
الشمال هو انتقل الى المرحله الثالثه ووضع
ما يقارب خمسه الويه بعد ان سحب اللواء
الخامس من الفرقه 143
في الوسط ايضا يريد الانتقال بسرعه الى
المرحله الثالثه ويعتبر الوسط وكانه
المنطقه الوسطيه او صله الوصل بين الشمال
والجنوب يركز اليوم على خان يونس وهناك
شيئان يحصلان في نفس الوقت السعي مع مصر
لتامين كوريدور فيلادلفيا وبالتالي هناك
فرق اساسيه تعمل على المنطقه العازله اما
جالن كما قال المرحله والحرب طويله ودائما
الاست هداف هو للانفاق وصواريخ القسام او
صواريخ المقاومه السيطره العسكريه على
قطاع
غزه يتحدث نتنياهو عن السيطره بعد الحرب
عسكريا على غزه هذا الامر كان محل انتقاد
من يقف جالانت وزير الدفاع لكن ب بحسب ما
نشاهده ونتابع من معطيات ميدانيه حاليا في
غزه هل بامكان جيش الاحتلال مهما طال امد
الحرب ان يسيطر فعليا على قطاع غزه
برايك هو في العقل الاسرائيلي الاستراتيجي
هذا الامر يخالف كل ما حضر له هذا الجيش
بالمعنى القتال لفتره طويله وبمعنى القتال
في حرب مدن وبالتالي حكم ارض او احتلال
شيء معين هذا الامر يستنزف القوات
الاسرائيليه ولكن دائما المعضله ال
الاسرائيليه اليوم هي الانتهاء من حماس
هذا امر لم يحصل الانتهاء من حماس كقوه
حاكمه سياسيه وكقوة